mit dem Handy hat arkanesi war
dokumentiert wie Sie und Ihre Familie
das Inferno erlebt haben alles ging so
schnell der blaue Himmel wurde erst grau
und dann schwarz alles was wir gesehen
haben waren Glut und Funken wir hatten
keine Ahnung was los ist es gab keine
Sirene nichts
Bilder die akanesi während der Flucht
selbst gefilmt hat die Flammen ziehen
schneller durch die Stadt als sie mit
dem Auto Vorankommen die 38-Jährige ihr
Mann und die drei Kinder müssen zu Fuß
weiter im dichten Rauch treffen sie die
Nachbarn
da haben wir uns gefunden und dachten
dass wir in einer Sackgasse sind mit dem
Rücken zur Wand wir schauten uns an und
mein Sohn fragte mich oh Mann was das
sagen
erinnert sich an den Moment der wohl den
Unterschied zwischen Leben und Sterben
macht sie geht in Fluchtweg noch einmal
ab auf dem Arm trug sie das Enkelkind
der Nachbarn ein Baby
und der Nachbar Bogen diesen Zaun dort
herunter und machten so den Weg frei
während die anderen hinter dieser
mauerkauerten
Kings gefeed will eine Kirche im Norden
von Maui hier verbringt Familie war
jetzt viel Zeit es gibt warmes Essen
Internet und Gespräche mit anderen
Betroffenen Halt finden Sie im Glauben
und im Kreis der Familie
ich bin dankbar dass mein Bruder und
seine Frau uns aufgenommen haben aber
hier zu sein auf dieser Seite der Insel
das bereitet mir immer noch Heimweh mein
Herz ist in laha
die Nacht die alles veränderte
bis in den Hafen fressen sich die
Flammen durch
der Wind peitscht das Feuer mit Funken
von Haus zu Haus
so klingt Verzweiflung
als an Land kein Platz mehr zum
Überleben bleibt flüchten viele über die
Felsen in den Ozean wie Noah tomkinson
und sein kleiner Bruder Milow
hilflos zusehen wie die Flammen die
Heimat auffressen
der Rauch färbt sich weiß ich glaube das
Feuer erstickt langsam sagt Noah als
immer wieder Explosionen zu hören sind
das Atmen wird zur Qual
[Musik]
Single von den Flammen verbringen diese
beiden Frauen die ganze Nacht in einem
Pool
nur im Wasser sind sie sicher
die Aschewüste die Maler war seit
einigen Tagen durch kämmen Trupps Haus
für Haus Auto für Auto so viele
Vermisste so unkenntlich das graue
Geröll was nicht aus Metall oder Beton
ist hat das Feuer eingeäschert
liche Überreste und sie zerfallen
einfach
Menschen herumlaufen haben wie gestern
darauf herum
ausgebrannte Autos entlang der gesamten
Uferstraße ein Stau als Todesfalle viele
Menschen schafften es nicht rechtzeitig
ins Wasser
drei Freunde von mir und ihre Hunde
starben im Auto ein Freund auf dem Boden
sah aus wie ein Stück Kohle wie ein
Pompeji da konnte man nichts mehr machen
so schnell ging das
polizeireguliert streng wer nach Lahaina
einfahren darf auch nach der Katastrophe
Stau auf der Hauptstraße wer Angehörige
vermisst soll DNA Proben abgeben
in den Tagen vor der Katastrophe habe es
auf Maui sogenannte red flag conditions
gegeben sagen Experten ideale
Bedingungen für ein Entfernung
gefährlichem Wind und niedriger
Luftfeuchtigkeit
es ist so intuitiv was diese Bedingungen
für Feuer bedeuten können dass wir zu
einem sehr exklusiven Wachstum der
Brände schneller Ausbreitung und hoher
Intensität er schafft unglaublich
schwierige Bedingungen für die
Unterdrückung und Eindämmung dieser
Brände
Bedingungen die durch den Klimawandel
weltweit immer häufiger auftreten aber
eine schnelle Lösung ist nach
Einschätzung einer führenden Expertin
nicht in Sicht
da geht es um viel längere Zeiträume und
nur wenn Regierungen Gemeinden und NGOs
zusammenarbeiten dann kann man die
Verluste von Menschenleben reduzieren
auch Schäden an Gebäuden
Lebensgrundlagen und Dingen die den
Menschen am Herzen liegen kann man
verhindern aber das alles müsste
langfristig angelegt werden
aber warum wurde nicht gewarnt warum
blieben die Sirenen stumm Fragen die
viele Menschen auf Maui nicht loslassen
Evakuierungen hätten wohl zumindest
viele Tote verhindert
mein Telefon piepte einmal als ich ins
Auto stieg das war die einzige Warnung
völlig nutzlos
normalerweise schalten Sie die Hurrikan
Sirenen an oder so um uns zu warnen es
gab nur Mundpropaganda
nicht mal die Polizei kam um uns zu
sagen dass wir evakuieren sollten oder
so
Fragen die hier in der
kingsi war und ihre Familie beschäftigen
sie feiern den Gottesdienst
Naturkatastrophen gab es auf Hawaii
schon immer aber so schlimm war es noch
nie
sie singen und beten gemeinsam für die
vielen Toten
[Musik]